So we're back in our editor now and we're going to create a basic material maybe for
this chair that we've already got in the scene.
It doesn't matter what actor you've got in the scene but for now I'm going to create
a material for a chair.
So I'm going to hit control and space bar to bring up my draw.
I'm going to go into my materials folder and if you were following along and you have a
static mesh filter or any kind of filter enabled here you can just click that off and you can
see that there's a whole bunch of materials in here.
So I'm just going to create a new one.
I'm going to right click in some free space.
I'm going to go to select material.
So just click in material from the empty space and just following the same naming convention
I'm just going to go M underscore chair and then I'll hit enter and then hit enter again
and that opens the material editor.
Now I want to pin this window next to my third person map just so I can toggle backwards
and forwards and it's also worth noting if this material didn't open by default for you,
if you had it deselected you can just hit control and space bar to open your drawer
again.
I'm going to go back to material and just double click it and then that will open the
material for you.
So before we were talking about base color we were talking about metallic and we were
talking about roughness.
So let's start with the base color.
Now the base color as we saw before was a vector 3.
So let's press 3 on our keyboard and left mouse click and that creates a vector 3.
So again 3 and mouse click and you can right click anywhere like we said in the example
and type in vector and try and find a vector parameter but I'm just going to show you some
shortcuts to make this workflow really work for you as you progress with your material
creation.
So first thing I want to do is I want to left mouse drag from this pin to that pin
and so we create a connection.
Next I want to select the node and I want to go to the color and just pick a color,
any color that you want from the color wheel.
So I'm just going to go there, I'm going to find a nice lilac pink type color and hit
OK.
And I'm going to save my material and let it save and then essentially we've just created
our first material.
So if I go back into my third person map I find the actor that I want and I hit control
and space bar and I can get this chair material and just drag and drop it over the chair and
now I have a pink chair.
Now you'll see that the material element has updated on the chair and I could have also
applied the material.
Say I want to favorite this material so I want to right click, I can't favorite the
material element right now but I could also if this, if I reset this value back to its
default value and that's just using this button I could also open my content drawer, have
this chair material selected, go back to here and plug that in there and it also works.
So that's our basic material right now set up but that's not really PBR, it's not getting
metallic and it's not getting roughness so let's go back into our material and now let's
add a metallic and roughness.
So I'm going to press and hold 1 and left mouse click and I'm going to drag that into
metallic.
I'm going to press and hold 1 and left mouse click and go into roughness.
Now you'll see on this window I'm going to right click to zoom in and out, left mouse
click to rotate but you can see this roughness at 0 and the metallic being at 0 is quite
a nice shiny material.
I'm going to first of all change this to 1 so you can see the result that happens there.
So you can now see it's gone very reflective and again metallic should really be between
0 or 1, the roughness could be a different value so we could put like 0.35 for example
and we bring down that roughness so going from 0 to 0.35 you can see it getting a little
bit more matted and if I went to 1 you could see it even more.
So depending on what value you want you can edit those, again this one more often than
not is 0 to 1, this one can be any version between 0 and 1.
If I save and I go back into my map you'll see that my chair looks a little bit cooler
now it's got a little bit more texture to it, it feels a bit more realistic which is
nice but I still want to edit some more properties maybe on the fly, maybe I want 2 or 3 chairs.
So I'm going to go to my material, first thing I want to do is right click on the colour
and I'm going to convert it to a parameter.
So right click on the actual node and I'm just going to type colour and I'm going to
type it the British way, you can type it whichever way is relevant to you.
I'm going to right click on metallic, convert to parameter, I'm going to type metallic and
we all spell that the same way and I'm going to right click on roughness and you guessed
it we spell roughness the same as well.
So roughness, metallic and colour, so right click on each one, convert to parameter, you
can convert it back to a constant if you want but these all need to be parameters so right
click and make sure you select convert to parameter on the top.
Now I'm going to save it and I can actually close this material now, so I'm going to close
it and nothing will have changed on the actual chair yet but the power comes in creating
these child material instances that we were referring to before.
So again I'm going to hit control and space bar, I've got the chair here, I'm going to
right click on the chair and create material instance which is the top.
So make sure you select the actual relevant material and create a material instance and
it just calls it m underscore chair underscore inst.
I tend to name my material instances mi underscore so I'm just going to rename this to mi underscore
chair and then I'm going to call it inst01 as well.
So completely up to you which naming convention you go for, you can see that it separates
the chairs out from the material as well because it's got mi instead of m but I prefer that
approach to have my material instances all in one place so I know that they're an instance.
When you hover over it as well it'll say in brackets material instance.
If you didn't have an opportunity to rename that you can either right click and select
rename or you can press F2 on the keyboard to rename it as well.
So I'm going to file save all right now just to make sure I have all my content saved and
now I want to show you the power of material instances.
So I'm going to select this chair, I'm going to hold down alt on my keyboard and left mouse
drag to create a duplicate.
I'm going to hold alt again and left mouse drag to create another duplicate.
Now what I want to do is I want to press control and space bar, I'm going to open up this instance
so double click the instance and you can see that I've got a metallic which I'm going to
select on, I've got a roughness and I've got a colour value.
This is all the condensed information of a material instance, this is just a childhood
version of that parent material and you can see that because I converted them to a parameter
they've now got their exposed values and the parent here is that chair.
So I could have called these values anything.
If I went back into the chair and if you're following along you don't need to do this
but I'm just showing you the relationship.
If I open the chair material, I'll just pin this here, if I hold down 1 and call this
hello and plug it into specular for example and I save, I went into here, I'll have a
hello variable.
So again the name doesn't specifically matter, it's good to keep things named consistently
but it's more just to demonstrate that there's a relationship now between this instance and
that big material.
And so now this is a really nice way to work.
So depending on your real estate you can move the windows wherever you want but I'm just
going to show you that by, I'm going to select this material, I'm going to make sure it's
selected in the content browser which is a quick draw.
If you have a second screen you could put this on a second screen.
So I'm going to select the material instance and I'm going to go to the chair, select the
chair and assign that.
So it's the new instance version of the chair.
Now the chair by default will look exactly the same because all these properties are
the same but what I can do now is maybe I want a blue chair or I want a green chair
or a gold chair or whatever colour I want I can now manipulate inside of this material
instance.
Maybe I want the metallic to actually be zero in this instance and maybe I want the roughness
to be one and I just want that chair to have that desired property.
And so that's a really powerful instance because if you look at the content browser I've not
edited this main material, this still houses all the information but the instance is now
having its own functionality.
So I'm going to right click on the instance, I'm going to click duplicate and it's going
to call it 02.
I'm going to duplicate it again and get an 03.
So 02 I'm going to put there, 03 I'm going to select there and let's edit 02 for a second.
So again I'm just bringing my window down so maybe I want a blue chair, maybe I do want
metallic on full and maybe I want zero roughness so it's just a nice reflective chair.
And then maybe the last one I want a, let's call it a red chair again with metallic and
maybe going back down to 0.3 on the roughness.
Let's save that and let's close it and you can see very quickly I can get very different
effects and so the material editor can have a whole bunch of parameters that you can change.
We've just done basic base colour roughness and metallic but you can imagine the powerful
functionality that's involved in creating these materials and then material instances
for you to edit content.
So hopefully that was a useful explanation of the material editor and then material instances
so that you can dive into the content yourself and start creating your own.